こんにちは はじめしゃちょーです
はぁああ
重大 な ご 報告 が ござい ます
私 はじめ社長 は
2019 年 8 月 7 日 を もち まし て
日本 を 飛び立ち
新電池 ドイツにて
活動 さ せ て いただき ます
こんな 重大 な ご 報告 が
ゲリゲリ に なっ て しまい 本当 に 申し訳 ござい ませ ん でし た
ドイツ に 行っ て も
変わら ず 元気 で 頑張っ て ください
まあ 僕 なんか は まだ 1 カ月 で
まんまり お 話 と か でき なかっ た です けど
ありがとう ござい まし た
まあ静岡はぼくたちが
はじめ さん なし で も 頑張る の で
また こっち に 帰っ て き た 一緒 に 楽しく 撮影 し たい です
8円 も 頑張っ て ください
きっともう
これ 以上
重 苦しい 空気 を 出す と
炎上 し そう な の で 早め に ドッキリ と いう こと
は？
ここ に
岩 し て い て いただき たい と 思い ます
にやー
ドイツ に しばらく 行く と いう の は
事実 で あり 決して
お前 それ 完全ニュウ素じゃぁ
おれはねェ
って いう わけ で は ござい ませ ん ドイツ に 行く こと は 事実 で あり
ううほわぁ
キャンキャン(犬)
その
ううドイ
そのドイツに行くために飛んでトリオ↑
こ↑こ↓ 1 週間 げ な
しぬ気で頑張っ て いて
つずゲットです
こんにちは はじめ 社長 です と いう わけ で 1 週間
ドイツ に 行っ て き ます
おそらく この 動画 が 出る とき は 僕 もう 実行 機 の 中 に 乗っ て もう
ドイツ へ の 向かっ て 空 の 旅 を 楽しん でる 頃 でshou
重低音
もぐ、もぐ
飛行機商品紹介
行ってくる 期間 は 一週間 な ん です けど も 1 週間 の ため撮りが超
きつっ た です あの本当 に 朝 から 晩 まで 動画 を ひたすら 撮り まくっ て  宝 動画 を 撮っ て い まし た
で 畑 も ある ん で
畑 分 も 取っ たら も 1 日 5 本 撮影 と か を もう 3 日 ぐらいばぁぁって あっ て やっ て もう
本当に
あの ユーチューバー 史上 最強 に 疲れ た 1 週間 だっ た な と 思い まし た
まあ katoいっ て ドイツ に 遊び に 行く わけ で も ない ん です けど　（ハンギレ
今回 なん で ドイツ に 行く か と いう と です ね
遊戯 王 カード の 世界 大会 が ドイツ で 開催 さ れ ます でそのドイツ で 開催 さ れる 遊戯王 の 世界 大会
の なん か こう な ん だろう レポーター から 公式
コメンテーター よく わかる ん です けど あ カルピス の 報酬 の 方 と 一緒 に ドイツ に 行っ て
世界 レベル の 大会 を 見 たり
皆 さん に 友情 の 良 さ を 伝え て いけれ ば いい な と いう 感じ で ござい ます もう
いい あんまり いそがしアピール し たく ない ん です けど 忙しかっ た です 1 週間 動画 撮れ なく なる だけ で こんな 地獄のような
日々 が 続く の か と 思っ て くらい 大変 だっ た ん で まぁ 多分 動画 に ある と 思う ん です けど も
ドイツで ちょっと また いろんな こと できれ ば いい か な と 思っ て 1 週間 ドイツに 入っ て まいり ます
で は
はじめは日本を見捨てた！
はじめは徒歩でドイツへ向かっている！
ぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺぷぺ
あっ ででで
五ーーーーーーーー
うっふふふ